What's up guys my name is Colin McNeil for
theScore esports.
Great commentary can elevate play in any
esport.
Turning the memorable into the unforgettable.
Making a good play into one that's iconic.
And nowhere is this more evident
than in the fighting game and Smash Bros.communities.
(Casting)
Yeeeaaah.
Ao anyways get your bionic arm out
and your Haagen Dazs scoops ready, because
we're doing the top 10 FGC and
Smash Bros. commentator calls.
Oh and right before we get into it guys, I'm gonna need
you to hit that YouTube wombo combo. That means hit subscribe,
like and do leave a comment.
Kicking off our list at number 10 is UltraDavid’s
iconic “Bionic Arm!” call
at Final Round 14.
It was Marvel vs. Capcom 3 winners’ semifinals and Combofiend
managed to claw his way back from the brink
of defeat with his final remaining character,
Spencer.
With a magic pixel of health, his Spencer
holds on for dear life, melting Marn’s Zero
and Sentinel and setting the stage for UltraDavid
to yell those famous words.
(Casting)
Coming in at number nine is D1 and his super fighting robot call.
During the Super Smash Bros. Invitational
at E3 2014, HugS released his Mega Man's final
smash, sending D1 into an absolute frenzy.
(Casting)
Making its way in at number 8 on our list is Bronson Tran at NCR 2017
Tran had the unique experience of commentating
his own matches at the NorCal Regionals 2017
Top 8.
He took the opportunity and ran with it.
(Casting)
Oh and by the way, he won the entire tournament too.
Number seven in our list is the call behind
Tokido’s infamous taunt combo at EVO 2017.
Sajam and James Chen were on the desk for
Street Fighter 5’s emotionally charged Grand
Finals, which featured a matchup between FGC
legend Tokido and rising star Punk.
In Game 1, Tokido styled on Punk like no one
had ever seen before.
We could describe the round for you, the surprise,
the shock and awe -- but honestly, no one
could have put it better than Sajam.
(Casting)
At number six we have Hellpockets
and Metaphysics at EVO 2017.
The King of Fighters 14 grand final saw E.T.’s
Daimon versus Xiaohai’s Iori, and featured
a perfectly timed Seismic Wave, plus one unforgettable
call.
(Casting)
At number five, we have SkiSonic and Yipes  crowning Marvel Vs Capcom’s returning
monarch.
Justin Wong and ChrisG went punch for punch,
until Justin popped off, reuniting himself
with the Marvel vs. Capcom throne.
(Casting)
You knew this one was coming.
An FGC commentary list just wouldn’t be
complete without Yipes and his brilliant stream
of consciousness Mahvel calls at Seasons Beatings
2. Oh he’s so pringles!
(Casting)
Unlike some of the other moments from this
Top 10, this Marvel vs Capcom 2 match, could
have been lost to time.
That is, if it wasn't for Yipes coming through
with one of the funniest, most memorable,
and quotable commentary in FGC history.
(Casting)
At number three, we have the Wombo Combo.
Phil, Mango, and HomeMadeWaffles were commentating the Loser’s semifinal at the SCSA West
Coast Circuit when SilentSpectre and Tang
decided to juggle Zhu.
What followed, was a call that would go on
to become an internet phenomenon….
(Casting)
Coming in at number two we have now iconic
commentary behind the Wong Factor comeback.
Facing off against Yipes at EVO 2007, Justin
Wong made an unforgettable comeback with only
his anchor, Cyclops, still standing.
It’s only fitting that one of the biggest
rallies in FGC history was complemented by
one of the hypest casting calls of all time.
(Casting)
Capping off our list at number one, is one
of the most memorable calls in all of esports, let alone fighting games.
A play that has been shown on ESPN’s Sportscenter
and made mainstream headlines around the internet.
At the Guilty Gear Xrd winner’s semis at
EVO 2015, Woshige made a very costly mistake
in celebrating one round too early.
(Casting)
Not only was the moment hella embarrassing
for Woshige, commentators Hellpockets and
Ryan Hunter famously scolded him for his premature
celebration.
(Casting)